it's mad that for all that people bang
on about slavery the only bang order
about transatlantic slavery that
finished 400 years ago was ended by the
british nobody bangs on about the fact
that there's more slaves now in the
world than the there was 400 years ago
at the peak of transatlantic slavery
leo kirsch welcome to the show
hello how are you doing i'm good man i'm
good how's the uk i'm heading back soon
where are you now in austin texas
oh really yeah i mean the uk's the uk's
all right uh we've got omicron going
around at the moment i've got omicron
right now in case you're wondering why i
sound kind of blocked up you're kidding
so
everybody's got it like basically you
know i'm always out doing gigs doing
shows and stuff doing i think i think i
might have actually got a um a tv studio
because i went in and everybody had a
cold and omicron is a cold basically so
um
yeah i had coronavirus had like the
original
and best first wave of coronavirus back
in august
and that absolutely floored me you know
what i mean i was like i wish i got
vaccinated but um
that that was bad uh and omicron i mean
it's still bad but it's like it's like a
cold it's not like
you know it's not like this is diet coke
what is diet coke yeah it's diet coke
complete with full fat coke so you've
got like the big the big full original
hit and then you've got like the new
version without caffeine without
anything else in
yeah which actually makes you fatter
because your body thinks it's had sugar
and it hasn't i don't know i am
i saw that omicron seems to be a little
bit more transmissible
but far less deadly or something there's
only one person that's died from it so
far
hugely more transmissible three and a
half times more transmissible and uh
covid was already a very transmissible
disease
so omicron basically you know
if you're near somebody's got it you're
probably going to get it except you know
sometimes you won't like my fiance it
doesn't doesn't have it
um
and
um
yes it's a lot less uh it's kind of it's
kind of flat this
the severity of hospitalizations is kind
of flat at about 25 to 30 percent um
whereas with the original covid
uh the severity started off very low uh
for like young people and then rose
dramatically for older people so it was
up around 85 90 percent for older people
um so this one's less severe overall but
slightly more severe for for young
people which is great because one of one
of the bad things about coronavirus is
like it didn't affect children so all
these annoying little snotty-faced brats
are running about
enjoying themselves and i think if
there's any justice i mean i did like
how coronavirus went for like the
the fat and the elderly and the
vulnerable you know
what i couldn't believe was like the
tories uh the tories tried to stop it
like coronavirus is basically enacting
tory policy or what i've been told tory
policy is
and then the tories try and stop like
next election i'm voting for coronavirus
it's doing a much better job at like
wiping out like vulnerable people than
the tories are
yeah it's so weird because um i learned
that viruses they
tend to get more lethal sorry less
lethal over time but more transmissible
and this is what we're seeing right that
omicron because killing the host is
actually a really rubbish way to
reproduce
so yeah that's why ebola ebola doesn't
get anywhere because you know everybody
dies before they can give it too lethal
yeah
yeah yeah it's a strange one i saw uh jk
rowling got herself in bother again eh
yeah yeah yeah so she tweeted um
because oh yeah so basically the police
in scotland scotland scotland's are
really weird got a really weird
government at the moment so they're
trying to be super woke
so there's they're sort of and i think
it's because they're uh propped up by
the green party
uh but the snp scotland's government uh
they're trying to be super woke with all
this sort of like uh
you know if you look at any adverts for
the scottish government or anything you
think scotland was like the most
multiracial cosmopolitan uh everybody's
in a you know dancing around with beards
and makeup and you know in a tutu and
stuff and scotland's not like that got
one blacklist
yeah it's got literally one black person
it's like scotland is 96 white
you know so it's bizarre that they're
trying to push this uh this image of you
know like they're a benetton uh advert
or like you know like a tiny tiny world
if you look at the smp
they think that scotland is like a
university prospectus cover
um it's
but
uh so they're trying they're bringing
through all this like walk legislation
and usually it's just used by them as a
as a lever to to do their dirty work so
um for example they've you know they
brought through the hate crime bill uh
and then used uh they didn't use the
actual bill but they used the sort of um
the uh emotion or the the momentum
behind it to depose uh so one of
sturgeon's enemies one of sturgeon's
rivals on the front bench joanna cherry
uh she was um she was knocked off for
the front bench uh because she was
accused of being transphobic and she's
she's not transformed she's um you know
she's a middle-aged lesbian she's you
know just a nice person um
but you know anything can be uh
construed as transphobic it's one of
those words it's like calling somebody a
witch
uh if you call someone racist or
transphobic it's you know you might as
well accuse no like
i never meet any genuine racists anymore
i used to when i lived in scotland but
like you know like in the 90s they were
genuine racists now you know it's very
hard to to find any genuine racist
there's people that say things that can
be misconstrued as racism and then that
slime is really difficult to get off
them
yeah yeah absolutely so yeah so it's
just you know if you accuse someone of
racism or transphobia you know you can
you can just destroy them but um yeah so
jk rowling um so police scotland have uh
have changed the law so that um if
uh if a biological male or a man
basically rapes someone um but then says
that they're a woman
police scotland bail will be like yeah
you're you're a woman and then they'll
be prosecuted and treated as a woman and
sent a women's prison even if you know
they're making no effort to
look like a
what we traditionally consider to be a
woman um
and you know obviously there's
huge issues with this you know women in
prisons um are incredibly vulnerable so
if you send biological males and
then
you know that's that's
that
that's obviously going to cause problems
particularly if that person's already
you know a rapist
and you can see why
a rapist would want to go to a women's
prison so they can continue raping
um
and
um so jk rowling did a tweet i mean you
might have it in front of you but it was
quite a clever um you know it was a play
on this orwellian uh new speak of uh
what happened under communism was
basically you had to
say the opposite of reality was true and
every day you were forced to say the
opposite of reality was true whether it
was you know
things are getting better we've all got
enough food to eat stalin's a great
leader um
you know you had to
chant all this stuff just just as you do
with woke ideology yeah you've got the
tweet from uh the tweet from jk rowling
was war is peace freedom is slavery
ignorance is strength the penis
individual who raped you as a woman
yeah
so i mean quite a pithy
incisive and clear
you know you can really see what she's
saying so obviously that's that's
denounced as uh transphobic when it's
it's not transphobic i mean she's not um
obviously you know jk obviously there's
transphobes out there but i think jk
rowling and me probably you
we recognize that you know transgender
women and transgender men who
really transition and really put the
effort in and you know want to live
as that gender um are genuinely you know
i know transgender women they're
genuinely trans transgender they're
genuinely women and i see them as women
um
but if you're just a bloke
who's saying that they're transgender
using you know exploiting the
self-identification rules to say that
they're a woman it's like no you're not
i don't understand the thing the thing
that i don't understand is that that
seems to me to
undermine genuine trans people's rights
more
than criticizing people that do that you
shouldn't want to have your
movement
and your identity co-opted by people who
genuinely don't believe it and just see
it as a an opportunistic way to move
themselves to a different type of prison
or to get out of um particular types of
culpability
yeah yeah no absolutely
it's scary man i don't know so i've
spent um
since i've been out here in austin i've
spent a good bit of time with a girl
called blair white you familiar with her
oh yeah yeah so i've spent a good bit of
time with blair who is a trans woman
and
[ __ ] hellman like it's been it's it's
the first time that i've spent a
significant amount of time around
somebody that's trans and it's really
been um like an eye-opener to me because
i s
it's easy to see her i mean have you
seen what blair looks like
oh yeah yeah i mean so she's she's about
as womanly as you're going to get she
looks like someone who's about to step
on a love island and yeah
it's it would be impossible to think of
her as
anything else but a woman and she
uh is pre-op she's not had the
downstairs surgery um but i mean well a
lot of transgender women don't have the
surgery because then you've got like uh
there's a one in three chance you'll
never orgasm again no way
yeah it's not a particularly you know
good or successful surgery to have okay
i didn't know that um but dude there's
no way that i couldn't see and this is
the thing i said this to to michael
o'malley who i was out with and i'm like
look dude
is it wrong for me to say
that it is so much easier for me to
treat blair like a woman because she
looked and acts and sounds and is shaped
like a woman yeah
no it's absolutely not wrong and that's
what you know all
um
you know i think
there's such a debate over like you know
what is a woman when when does a
transgender woman become a woman and i
think there's obviously a hotness rule
there's obviously a hot like if you
reach a certain level of hotness you can
use the women's toilets you can use the
women's changing rooms and if you're
just like a bloke with a beard and stuff
no you can't use the women's changing
rooms because you're not a woman and i'd
apply this to biological women as well
so i mean a lot of the turfs who are you
know criticizing me for uh for saying
transgender women are women you know i
was looking at some of them
and it's like you're barely classifiable
as a mammal like how can you be sitting
there like this dumpy you're a mid-50s
like you know hairy chin
harridan battle axe but you know these
women are women it's like you're not a
woman
like blair white is way more way more of
a woman than
some of these
turfy
old bents you know what i mean well i
mean blair even committed she's
committed so much to being a woman that
she even drives badly
so that
that was being in her car she's got a
bright pink mustang
which so i pulled out of the gym and
drove past where joe rogan's recording
studio is which is supposed to be the
semi-secret but pretty much everybody in
austin knows where it is and there's
this bright pink
[ __ ] ford mustang
outside i'm like if anyone wanted to
advertise not only that blair white's on
his show but also where the studio is
it's like pull that thing up outside but
yeah man i mean she she literally even
drives
like a woman and it's so um
it's been really eye-opening been really
really eye-opening to spend some time
around somebody who you know
i i think that
the first time or one of the times that
she did mushrooms she looked in the
mirror and for the first time she saw
herself as a woman and you think okay
that's somebody who genuinely has
a
discordance between how they see
themselves and how the rest of the world
sees them and how they feel inside and
that this kind of reframed you know
born in the wrong body gender identity
all of this sort of stuff
and um
yeah not that i wasn't
sympathetic previously but i'm even more
empathetic now you know like i can
genuinely see the the trials and
tribulations of somebody who wants to be
something different and why the [ __ ] in
whose world how much of a [ __ ] would i
need to be to not call her
she
i would need to be a colossal prick to
not do that um so of course i'm like i'm
absolutely sweet with that but on the
flip side like you say some guy
[ __ ] hairy chested six foot three guy
with massive hands and a [ __ ] beard
like that decides to go and attack
somebody
and is then just uses a
self-identification rule to get out of
that that feels to me
like more of an attack on trans rights
than saying that that shouldn't be the
case
exactly because that's i mean stories
like that that tend to make it into the
news or onto social media so then
everything so that's what transgender
people are when in reality most
transgender people i mean for a start a
lot of them pass a lot of them you walk
past them in the street you wouldn't
even know like blaire white you met her
you wouldn't know that she's she's not
um originally you know biologically
female um
so you know most of the
transgender people certainly certainly
the ones i know they want to they want
to get on with their lives and not have
this spotlight thrown in them and it's
brought there by um by you know
basically basically blokes uh saying
that they're women trying to explain i
mean there's some funny examples like
will franken who's actually from texas i
don't know if you know him no
he's a comedian um really really funny
comedian but a bit crazy but um
he
and he sort of preempted all this about
five years ago uh he basically said he
was a woman
and
then you know he started getting lots of
work with the bbc and stuff and um but
he wasn't he just put a put a frock on
and that was it but it was really funny
like you know
you'd turn on radio 4 and they'd be like
we're here with the female comedian and
uh he started calling himself sarah
frank and female comedian sarah frank
and he'd be like hey oh you doing you
know what i mean
i remember i booked him i booked him for
a show a show that ran hayton live
really fun show it's basically
improvised hatred based on audience
suggestions uh really fun to do but it
was at the end of fringe and um so he or
she
sarah franken at the time
excuse he's gone back to being a man now
but uh sarah franken booked her and she
was standing outside smoking a cigarette
and she was like huddled under the
awning because it was raining and the
bouncer saw you know this six foot two
bloke in a frock uh you know with a wig
you know smoking a cigarette the bounce
was like you move away from the from the
entrance please and uh sarah just turned
around and it's like you're gonna make a
lady smoking the rain like it's the
funniest thing i've ever seen mine
[ __ ] man i don't know it's all it's all
up in the air but then jk rowling's been
written out of the fantastic beasts
trailer you see that that's just got
released today
man it's it's a ridiculous like it's
ridiculous and like obviously somebody
like jk rowling she's got her billions
of pounds she's still making money from
the fantastic beasts and whatever but
she's not said anything that's
particularly horrific she said stuff i
mean she said stuff that maybe i
wouldn't agree with like but other
people say stuff that i don't agree with
i don't think they should be like you
know removed from her own body of work
exactly yeah jk rowling's name has been
downgraded in a trailer promoting the
latest film of a fantastic beast series
amid a row over views on trans
identification unlike previous adverts
for the franchise rowling's name barely
features in the two and a half minute
trailer for the third installment
fantastic beasts something something
something the new trailer opens with the
caption warner bros invites you while
the 2018 film said jk rowling invites
you and creditor credited her with
writing and producing her film kiri
tunks co-founder of the campaign group
women's place uk told the daily
telegraph this attempt to detach a
female author from her own creative
achievement is astonishing but is just
the latest episode in a long history of
women being raised so now you have the
intersecting
uh groups of of concern coming in okay
so we actually more bothered about women
and their
progress are we more bothered about
protecting trans people and their
progress and people that aren't actually
trans and are pretending to be
yeah
it's a difficult one man i don't know i
don't know how this ends up ends up
finishing but jk rowling continues to
get herself into hot water
quite easily
yeah just by saying stuff that's you
know fairly pithy and you can see the
point she's making and it's like we
should be able to make
points we should be able to say that
like you know if a man
uh rapes a woman um he's
you know there's an issue with him then
saying that he's a woman and going to
try going to a women's prison the you
know it's
really obvious
truth this is the thing that really
surprised me about walkism is how how
similar is to communism and that you're
not allowed to say really obvious truths
and everybody has to pretend that the
the lie is the truth against the sort of
party lines so to speak i mean yeah
yeah i don't know man especially given
the fact that you don't need to have
gone through legal changes you don't
need to have shown that you've been
transitioning for a period of time and
it's like [ __ ] do you know what it is if
you haven't done those things and if you
rape somebody like the benefit of the
doubt gets to go out of the window
you've sequestered
any good will
from society if that happens and who the
[ __ ] who the [ __ ] supposed to be
defending rapists here have we got onto
a situation where rapists are being
defended
yeah yeah but the ideological strength
of the sort of trans rights or a certain
section of the trans rights movement
i don't think the representatives don't
think they speak for a lot of trans
people but the the ideological purity
overrides you know any sort of real
world uh
questions or you know anything like the
fact that you know
what about a rapist it's ridiculous when
i was
i was talking to um india willoughby
who's a trans journalist um
so she she called andy no a nazi so you
know i just did a tweet about how you
know the word nazi has been devalued so
much that you know this this gay being
uh journalist uh the son of vietnamese
refugees who you know exposes uh
corruption hypocrisy and violence and on
the left um you know is deemed a nazi
and uh you know she turned turned out
somebody somebody added to the the
threads saying that um
andy willoughby had described described
him as an uncle tom which is obviously a
viciously racist thing to to say
um
and
he misgendered india
when he said it and then he was like
you've misgendered me as if that was
the thing that we should all be paying
attention to not her
uncle tom yeah precisely yeah [ __ ] dude
my favorite andy knows story is a video
that anyone can go and watch on youtube
and it's people other people being
mistaken for andy know
auntie for rallies have you seen this
oh [ __ ] dude it is so you need to do you
need to do a video on this so um there's
a guy asian dude walking through a
antifa
uh
like
rally thing people holding placards
there's a guy holding a a camera and
they're shouting at him going are you
[ __ ] andy no [ __ ] you andy and then
people start going up to him and this
dude he's got a mask on right so he
comes up to them takes the mask off and
he says are you being serious like this
is the third time that this has happened
to me now and the guys are like what so
you're telling me that just because i'm
asian and i look like andy know that
you're going to abuse me from the side
of the street and the person that stood
next to the guy holding the camera goes
well it kind of seems like you're doing
it on purpose and he's like doing what
being asian
[ __ ] man that's amazing it's so good
but that's the most pejorative thing
like think about how [ __ ]
judgmental that is it's so deeply racist
like there's an asian guy possibly andy
no let's get him
[Laughter]
what about the uh government's
conversion therapy bill what's happening
there
well i just i just did a video about it
and so basically the government's uh
bringing through this bill to ban
conversion therapy which sounds like a
good good idea on the face of it because
you know conversion therapy historically
has involved you know elect
administering electric shocks to to gay
people uh while they watch gay porn
which obviously doesn't stop them being
gay it just introduces them to
a fetish um and uh yeah like all kinds
of laying on of hands praying
um like lou reed lou reed was subject to
this i mean this this only stopped in
the or you know stopped being
administered by the by the state or by
official authorities and i think it was
about the 70s so it's you know
relatively uh recent thing that stopped
um and you know in the old days they did
things like transplanting testicles um
to try and uh make people straight it
was you know crazy but like the
testicles were the
center the epicenter of the gayness
i guess that's that's what the thought
was it's the epicenter of your your
sexuality so that is [ __ ] medieval
isn't it jesus even even lobotomies and
stuff as well so um it's crazy because
homosexuality up until like the 60s or
the 70s was actually classified as a
mental illness
um
and
you know it's obviously it's barbaric i
mean it still goes on you know sometimes
particularly with you know religious
groups and um
you know it's bad but what the what the
government's conversion therapy bill
does is
uh it also bans uh it classifies um
any sort of treatment for gender
dysphoria
um other than um
actually transitioning classifies that
as a conversion therapy so if you
but a lot of transgender people
especially you know children teenagers
um they're presented
they're confused about their sexuality
or they've got um
depression or anxiety or there's other
things
that are affecting it and between the
the data we've got the moment says that
between 60 and 90 percent of them uh
will reconcile to their biological uh
gender their natal gender um
if allowed to but the the system we've
got at the moment is is just funneling
them into into treatment because the
only
current
procedure which is permitted is to
reassign gender yeah so they're put on
puberty blockers which are
you know they say oh this is just to buy
time uh but it's
it's not it starts a sort of cascade and
they're put into into
a sort of conveyor belt um that um leads
them to to be given cross-sex hormones
and then surgery and it happens
surprisingly quickly considering the
sort of you know how dramatic and how
you know powerful the side effects of
some of these things are um so a lot of
the drugs the hormones the puberty
blockers they um they can cause
infertility they can weaken bones um you
know cause all sorts of problems also
the surgery um you know if you remove
breaths that's permanent um
if you uh you know transition the
genitals with surgery that's permanent
causes infertility as well so there's a
lot of there's a lot of issues with with
this but you know children and this
industry has just sort of exploded um
just a few years ago there's just one
there one gender transition clinic in
the states now there's over 300 so this
huge industry has blown up and
they're not allowed to have a sort of
free and honest and open debate around
it because academia and the medical
industry systemically woke so any
questioning of any of this is seen as uh
as transphobic
silenced and shut down and any academics
that research it um even if even if
they're you know taking a balanced look
and being uh you know sympathetic um to
transgender people they get they get
denounced and their their books are
banned and um they get you know thrown
out of their universities so
there isn't the data and there isn't the
the debate and the
the sort of academic research that is
really needed um to
you know to judge what's best and this
this bill sort of adds to that by by um
outlawing any treatment other than
gender
uh
gender reassignment surgery yeah so
what's what's being implied there is
that nobody that could suffer with
gender dysphoria would want to not
continue with their gender dysphoria
like if if you were to try and reverse
that or if someone was to try and stress
test your uh ideas around your own
gender identity um that is also now put
underneath trying to turn gay people
straight again
yeah yeah exactly it's classed as the
same kind of thing which is which is
ridiculous and not based on any data and
also the
you know the there isn't really a huge
problem with the gender um with sorry
with conversion therapy in in the uk we
don't have
we don't have a huge amount of um
you know people administering electric
shocks to gay people to try and make
them straight it's something that
happened in the 60s and isn't happening
now
i couldn't believe that that was even
like still a thing even slightly still a
thing i mean when i first saw this and i
didn't realize the externalities to
people that are suffering with um gender
dysphoria for their gender identity i'm
like what the [ __ ] what is this is this
alan turing back from the dead to become
medically castrated again it feels so
medieval
yeah well alan turing is you know a
famous um
victim of conversion therapy so yeah
chemical castration i think he chose
chemical castration because the option
was going to jail
uh for for being gay and obviously
jail is
you know if you're gonna if you're
thinking of a punishment jail is not
where you want to send gay people
they're going to have a great time in
there didn't you
[Laughter]
well wasn't it something that you said
about um
some of the conversion therapy things
were just putting loads of boys in a
room with priests for a couple of weeks
yeah yeah yeah they pray the gay away
camps one of my mates went to got sent
to one and it's ridiculous i mean like
you know
like
if you take like 200 gay teenage boys
and put them at a camp together overseen
by priests there's not going to be less
anal sex going on in that camp you know
what i mean
so um yeah
pretty stupid
it's the worst conversion therapy of all
time everyone's just come back really
really skilled
yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah or maybe
maybe they have maybe it's like when
your dad catches you smoking a cigarette
and it makes you smoke the whole pack
like you know these kids are going to
come back
the camp arsenal's like a car crash so
that's how it works
[ __ ] have you heard of black fishing do
you know what this is
no okay so uh jessie nelson former
little mix singer addresses music video
controversy
yeah i did see this so she's she's been
accused of um and this has happened to a
few people in public it's happened to
louise orwell and the comedian
so they get accused of um appropriating
black culture to try and be cooler yes
which which
really i mean it is cooler black culture
is a fabric like white people why people
culture isn't exactly the coolest thing
on the planet and i don't think that any
black person would say that it is either
stick to your own cool culture former
little mixed singer jesse nelson said
she never intended to cause a fence
after being accused of black fishing in
her debut solo track the singer 30 was
criticized by some people in social
media for her appearance in the video
for boyz
nelson was accused of black fishing a
practice of none of a non-black person
trying to appear black
but is denied using fake tan
i can't believe that they're like we'll
get the dulux color chart out jesse have
you gone below an eight here because
that nine that is not to be used by you
at all uh also nicki minaj has got like
based over the last couple of months
hasn't she
i haven't seen anything by nicki minaj
but i do know that like if you go like
the whitest cities like glasgow uh
newcastle as well uh you know where
we're from you go there people are
people really put on the tan and they go
to tanning salons and you know glasgow
man you think you're debris like oompa
loompa color yeah it's insane yeah i
don't know i mean
i think that another problem isn't just
the way that because she didn't have
dreads it wasn't like
how would you say
uh
[Music]
archetypal
ancient sort of the the commonly held
desires of black people and the way that
their grandparents would have dressed
it's like
wearing a pair of air force ones
and
baggy tracksuit bottoms it's hardly what
i see as the crux of black culture
yeah yeah absolutely absolutely there's
no do-rag you know there's no
um
you know feathers or anything oh here we
go he was another one actually uh nelson
said she was fortunate to easily tan
when in the sun and told me so she did
it live i can't believe that you need to
go and do an instagram live with nicki
minaj to try and rehabilitate your
public image told me that she did yeah
pretty much
uh
somebody had previously commented on her
propensity to tan okay so she's got an
alibi to how easily she tans
uh she said that her hair is naturally
curly after complaints that she had
changed her style in the music video she
added i genuinely didn't think i was
doing anything wrong because i've got
naturally curly hair i'm looking at a
photo of her and she's ginger and i've
never seen a black ginger person so i
mean if you want justification
yeah did you understand why people when
they get called out by stuff like this
why you know why is she coming out and
be like oh i tan really easily and i've
got natural curly hair just come out and
say like mind your own [ __ ] business
like you know obviously women always
change they're here they want you know
if they've got straight here they want
curly hair they've got curly hair they
went straight here it doesn't mean that
they're they're calling for uh you know
the fourth reich to uh to rise and
dominate with aryan nations like it's
ridiculous
like you're allowed to like you know put
on a bit of makeup and change your hair
if you want
i don't know it's um
the whole idea around now
people sort of staying in their lane you
know actors playing the
appropriate role for whatever their
gender sexuality orientation
background disability yeah correct yeah
which i mean
i don't know where do you stand on that
man i think they're actors they're
they're acting and i think if you if you
narrow the field down if you say that
only
um
you know only transgender people can
play transgender roles number one you're
narrowing the
num the field uh potential talent down
to an incredibly narrow field and also
you're making it less likely that those
stories will get told so
you know
there's two ways that is it's negative
for for the film and for for transgender
people also
you've had some pretty good actors come
out of scotland and if they're only
permitted to play scottish people
they're fairly limited you know i mean
no one was no one was looking at killian
murphy when he did
uh peaky blinders and saying uh excuse
me killian can we actually check if you
weren't born in ireland and we're from
the the town of solihull or whatever
instead but that's no one's no one's
fact checking him so yeah it's very much
particular protected groups that have
the problem
yeah
i don't know yeah absolutely and
anything like that um you know where
particular groups are sort of deified
and placed higher than other groups in
the sort of oppression pyramid and so
nobody like you know a black person
wouldn't get in trouble for um
straightening their hair um and a
transgender person would get in trouble
for playing a
whatever
like a norm a woman like if they're if
they're a transgender person they'd be
celebrated for it so what's what that's
doing is uh placing a seed of um
uh
you know dissatisfaction in everybody's
mind that why why are these people
getting treated different why do they
get special treatment um which obviously
isn't good for for social cohesion and
the rights of everybody in the long run
i saw you have a debate about censorship
and comedy which descended into the
history of women's football
what happened there oh yeah
yeah with kate smirthwaite do you know
kate smirkwood no she's got very
standy outy neck veins
uh i noticed that that you managed to
cause
some serious neck vascularity to happen
during that debate that was the main
thing i took away from it
yeah yeah
it was uh it was hilarious basically she
um so it was on sunday it was on gb news
and we were debating freedom of speech
and comedy and she came up with all
these bizarre claims like she says she
hears racist jokes every month she hears
racist jokes uh
told by other comedians that gig she's
doing and like i i don't hear racist
jokes i you know i gig most nights and
um
you know i do working men's clubs and
all the rest of it you know i do shows
in london i do do anything in book for
butlins whatever i don't hear any racist
jokes and uh i'm considered uh to be a
you know far-right nazi racist homophobe
transphobia and all the rest of it so
i'd think that i'd be putting bills with
the racist comedians if if there were
any uh i never hear any i know why i
don't hear any because if you told a
racist joke
on stage at comedy club people wouldn't
like it because it's 2021
and we're performing in front of you
know every time we perform or perform in
front of a group of people
who are just you know members of the
public so if you say anything that's
socially unacceptable they won't accept
it because that's how socially
unacceptable works um but yes and kate
said she's you know and she's doing all
these like what the only gig she she
does she's a comedian
she's a comedian you are kidding me
i could have sworn that she was some
sort of i don't know journalist editor
lady i didn't know that she was a
comedian well i haven't i haven't
actually gigged with her in a comedy
club since uh like we did the jersey
comedy festival in like 2012 or
something um so yeah it's been like
eight or nine years since i've actually
performed with her um
and so maybe maybe she's not really a
community i looked on her um gigs list
online and there's no gigs booked in
so
i don't know i don't know where she's i
don't know where she's performing that
other people are doing racist jokes but
i think you know she might have been
lying
um
and yeah she said uh yeah the the
women's football thing you know because
people
should she was saying it was right that
roy chubby brown should have been
cancelled and people were right to write
in letters and stuff so roy chubby brown
is due to perform in sheffield
and he was cancelled by
sheffield council because they said it
doesn't reflect the values of sheffield
council and it's like yeah he's not
supposed to reflect the values of
sheffield he's not the mayor he's a
[ __ ] comedian and like i don't want
to go and see some like uh council value
show that sounds [ __ ] that sounds so
boring i don't want like man i used to
work in local government and they're all
so wasteful and boring and [ __ ] we
should just do away with them just get
like you know a small council that like
collects the bins and keeps keeps the
roads in good nick um
but yeah so they canceled roy chubby
brown and she was saying it's right that
they cancelled canceled them and uh i
was just saying
like i just don't think
you know like if you don't want to go
see a comedian if you don't think a
comedian's good or funny just don't go
and see them i did a show at one of my
favorite clubs in london um and somebody
wrote a letter
into the club or wrote an email into the
club saying uh i came to see leo
curtis's show in july at your venue and
it was horrifically offensive and
horrible
and i came back to see it again in
november and it was still horrifically
offensive and horrible please cancel him
from you you know your club it's like
instead of cancelling me
why don't you stop coming to the show
you know what i mean
like
it's absolutely ridiculous i don't even
think they were at the show because they
said it was like homophobic and all the
rest of it i didn't say anything like
the club film everything because you've
got to these days to you know cover
yourself and they reviewed the footage
and realized i hadn't said any of the
stuff that would you
mean that they need to film everything
to cover yourselves what's that
so if somebody says oh you know this
person said something misogynist they
need to be able to review the footage
and see no way and that's happening
that's common practice in the uk
yeah yeah it seems to be now i record
everything every show that i do i record
the audio so you know if anybody
complains that i've got that as a no
[ __ ] way
people wonder why comedy is becoming
incredibly bland and comedians are
self-centering so much you know
that's wild
yeah so how did it get onto
women's football what's that got to do
with it oh yes a women's football
i can't really remember i just said like
women's football is like
uh women's football's [ __ ] and
um
uh
yeah i can't even remember oh yeah no
that's right i said what comedy what
comedy is like women's football uh it
gets written about a lot in the guardian
but it's [ __ ]
and that wound kate up so you know i
hammered it home some more saying how it
was going to get she had a she had a
an idea around was it world war ii when
so she said she said the reason women's
football isn't popular isn't because
it's [ __ ] the reason women's football
isn't popular
is because
she genuinely said this with straight
faces because it became incredibly
popular during world war ii when all the
men were you know of war uh getting
themselves blown up because um the
patriarchy favors men and um
she said so women's foot when when the
men came back from the war uh the
authorities suppressed women's football
and we're now eating the
progeny of that
the woman's football was lambasted in
the
40s and 50s and 60s which has caused us
today to have an aversion to watching
women play football but i'm more than
happy to watch woman sport
if they're good at it but i watch the
game yeah i wish or if they're fit i'll
watch it if they fit like the volleyball
in the olympics correct that's
more than most sport i mean football
it's barely a sport volleyball in the
olympics is bearish but let's it's
softcore porn that gets played before
the watershed
yeah um
i watched a game of cricket
uh the hundred which was a a competition
this year they did a special 100 ball
game and um the way that they did it was
they had the
the
ladies game from the same teams and then
the men's game uh straight after each
other so you could go and go and watch
and uh i watched
one innings have eight dropped catches
now i could go and see an under 11's
game
and not see eight dropped catches
i'm like look i'm all for supporting
women's sport but if you can't [ __ ]
catch the ball
this is not this is no longer a sport
think of the number of dents in the car
park
and
but oh oh the halftime sandwiches
it's just an amazing spread well that's
it yeah like that's only because you
have a high proportion of female
cricketers i think that a lesbian so
you've got like two
two really good people in the kit i mean
i remember i remember when i was
when it would be one of the lads that
didn't have a partner and it was his
turn to make the lunches when we used to
play cricket and it would be him and
whoever his housemates were and it would
be the worst spread it's quite a good
way to do it because he'd never be asked
back to do it you would only ask the
people that had female partners so yeah
actually that's that's one way to look
at it but yeah i'm [ __ ] i'm all for
supporting women's sport
if they're good at the sport you can't
you can't force it down people's throats
yeah that's the thing though like i mean
sport is pretty much a meritocracy you
know if something's popular if somebody
wants to watch it it's not like any
promoter is going to be like oh no i'm
not going to promote this because it
goes against my sexist beliefs they want
to make money
they want to make money so they'll put
on women's football if it's going to
shift tickets
but like does kate does kate smarthwaite
have a season ticket for for women's
football she doesn't swansea town wfc or
whatever yeah yeah yeah yeah people talk
it but they you know they talk
think about um the ufc
the ufc regularly has uh female fights
as the the title fight of the night
final fight of the night like
and those are those are unbelievably
talented athletes and i'll happily watch
two women smash seven shades of [ __ ] out
of each other just as happy as i will a
man like and i don't care they're
they're faster the knockouts are a
little bit less powerful but they're
still like dope to watch
oh yeah yeah down
but eight drop catches
that if or if all that the girls did was
circle each other in the ring and like
do do that thing i wouldn't want to
watch it yeah yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] man
eight drop catches that is mad
disgusting
did you see the um the hubbub around
this university of pennsylvania trans
swimmer you seen this one
okay so um
because this is this trans athlete
that's an area where it does kind of um
you know a lot of the arguments do break
down you've got like laurel hubbard who
uh you know transition when she was in
her third competed as a male athlete
previously so it's like that's not fair
you know what i mean that's not fair
no i mean this was fallon fox and ufc
you know like the
women that fought her said you know i've
never experienced strength like that and
obviously because that's like a man
who's like you know totally hulked out
and stuff so you got like you know going
through male puberty conveys certain
advantages to
transgender athletes you get like um you
know bigger skeleton stronger bone
structure greater muscle mass it's
easier being on a course of testosterone
a high course of testosterone compared
with your gender for
35 years and then decided to pivot it
out so yeah um it's possible you've done
steroids for 30 years and then like you
know
cycled off and said right i'm not going
to compete
it's impossible to beat her despondent
female rivals say swimming against trans
leah thomas is intimidating and
discouraging after teammates spoke out
and said everyone knows it's wrong she
beat her next closest opponent by a full
38 seconds
and won pretty much everything basically
she broke two national records when she
competed she'd competed up until 2019
and then had a little break and come
back there's something i don't know how
you feel about this man there's
something that feels particularly
i i really don't know where i stand on
the trans women in
sports
discussion
because
it is you do want people to be able to
compete in their chosen pursuit and if
they're good and so on but then also you
know that there's this unfair advantage
but then making a trans women only
division also doesn't really feel like a
particularly good outcome making them
continue to compete with men also
doesn't feel like a particularly good
outcome i i kind of struggle to see a
good way what about what about if we put
them in the paralympics and then instead
of women getting beaten by 38 seconds it
was somebody with down syndrome getting
beaten by like four hours and 12 minutes
would that be a good solution
no
no we can't do that either that's good
suggestion but i'm not convinced that
that's going to work um
but
there's something that that feels
particularly egregious about it being
college athletes or like kids
because you know that at that stage
there's more branches of life open to
them right there's more paths that they
could go down to sponsorships
scholarships paths to go to university
and move into professional sport and
stuff like that
i don't know there's something about
that do you get that sense as well that
there's just something like extra unfair
about trans athletes in college that are
taking spaces from other athletes i
don't know
yeah i mean like
the whole thing about athletes is i feel
like they've got an unfair advantage
through some trick of biology anyway um
so i'm kind of you know and also i'm not
i'm not a feminist i'm delighted to see
uh women upset that they've been beaten
by a biological male
so um yeah i mean i can't really see i
can't really see the downside it's um
you know
like and you look at also look at the
women weightlifters that laurel hover
was competing against they weren't like
dainty little like made maidens they're
like
they look like you know big old lumps as
well
um
i mean obviously if i was a woman or a
you know cared then i'd think
differently but um i genuinely
um
i genuinely just quite enjoy watching
feminists and
and
transgender rights activists tear each
other apart on on things like that
i don't know what's going to happen as
you continue rolling forward with the
intersecting ideologies of
whoever's that got the most grievance
like
it feels like it's got to be a snake
that eats its own tail at some point do
you not think
yeah it's already it's already so
convoluted and so
um
it's so communist in the the sort of the
way that ideology works that you know if
jk rowling
you know pulls back the curtain to
reveal the lie that you know you've got
like so
you know i if i said i'm a woman like
according to all these like woke
ideologists the trans rights ideologist
i'm now a woman and it's like well
obviously not i'm just there's a
fundamental difference between you and
blair white
yeah yeah yeah
i don't know man i don't know i don't
know how that ends up
how this sort of situation ends up
finishing itself because it's going to
fragment itself and continue to fracture
into so many different groups and
subgroups that yeah what's left
yeah and we've we're already seeing it
happening with the um lgbtq community as
you now got the lgb alliance because a
lot of lesbian and gay people feel that
they're being erased by and you know
quite quite rightly because if somebody
um if a child or you know a young person
teenager whatever presents um with
gender dysphoria um
quite often that's because they've got
like their same sex attracted and um you
know they're being sort of coached that
that's because they're born in the wrong
body rather than their homosexual um
and then they're putting the the pathway
to you know this conveyor belt to
transitioning um and you can see you
know a lot of lesbians are quite
manly quite [ __ ] um and a lot of gay
guys are quite effeminate um
so
they'd be the ones being put on the the
path to transitioning now and it's i i
mean this is actual state policy in iran
which has got the highest level of uh
you know transitioning
um in the world but basically being
being gay in iran is illegal so um
you've got the choice between uh you can
either be gay and go to jail or be be
killed or you can transition to being a
woman and then it's fine you know once
you've got like you know they're sort of
the state is transitioning thousands of
people in iran and um
what we're seeing now is people wanting
to de-transition um
and reconcile with their biological
gender
um but it's it's difficult once you've
been on once you've had the puberty
blockers and the hormones and the
surgery it's very difficult to untangle
that and re rework yourself so i think
you know we're storing up problems this
is going to be the thalidomide of our
era uh 10 years time there's going to be
so many people who are like you know a
confused uh 13 year old and were
sort of brought into this this pathway
to transitioning
and are going to be um absolutely
distraught and wanting to de-transition
and obviously it's not you know i'm not
saying everybody is going to be like
that for a lot of people it is the right
the right thing to do but
they're they're scooping up everybody
and applying you know the same
the same treatment to everybody
um
that's what andrew doyle talks about the
fact that he thinks a lot of um
gender reassignment for children is
rehabilitated
uh
concern about homosexuality
it's being it's rehabilitated homophobia
looked at through a different lens that
parents don't want i can't remember who
it was he quotes this guy who said um
he knew that his little boy was always a
girl when he said that he was attracted
to guys and he's just so glad that his
son isn't mincing about talking to boys
anymore
are you like exactly
pure homophobia is no one [ __ ] seeing
this
yeah yeah that's basically iran's state
policy that's the guy's basically
channeling the ayatollah khamenei right
there
[ __ ] hell man i don't know i don't
know there was a um a denver elementary
school that put a sign outside
advertising families of puller of colour
playground night so they've essentially
created a racially segregated play time
for equity
they did this a lot sainsbury's did it
as well they had
safe spaces
um for
for ethnic employees um
which you know
the thing with any sort of separation by
by race
is you know it's separating people by
race is
whether you say you're doing it for an
altruistic or a positive reason doesn't
matter because you're separating by race
and then it then it gives
um it gives
sort of ammunition or validates anybody
who wants to separate people by race for
for nefarious reasons for racist reasons
there was a was it a 12
days uh 12 weeks a slave
workout
that was released last year was that by
sainsbury's as well because
it was something like being because
being a slave was hard and so is this
workout
oh yeah yeah i remember that that wasn't
sainsbury's that was a personal trainer
was it
then then had a had an internet pile on
uh which is kind of unfair because i
mean i think i think it was black
um and he had this pylon uh he just kind
of thought it through but he's a person
it is poor marketing yeah he's thinking
but if he could think things through he
wouldn't be a personal trainer you know
i mean getting paid like 12 pound an
hour
to like help housewives do setups like
obviously it's not going to be the brain
of britain
ah i don't know this is
the whole racially segregated thing is
is kind of a little bit
of a weird one because
i think
one one argument that i saw to do with
denver i don't know much about denver
apparently not a lot of black people uh
so
it
you're
finding a way for people to be able to
create a community but it feels like
anything that's bureaucratically forced
top down anything that's dictatorial and
not just look if you want to hang
together in the schoolyard or after
school or when you collect people like
who the who the [ __ ] the elementary
school to say that this is the way that
we should
exist in the world and it's terrible
it's drawing attention to racial
differences rather than sort of you know
because i was i was always brought up
you know school taught us that you know
race is only skin deep and obviously
it's not there's cultural differences in
all the rest of it um but we were taught
to sort of be friends with each other
when we were in scotland so it didn't
make any difference there weren't any
black people but um but yeah
and certainly you know i've got black
friends who say you know things are
regressing things are getting worse
because it used to be that everybody
would just hang it together and now
we're having this sort of top-down
enforced
um separation of people
and you know sainsbury's
companies are exploiting it and
exploiting the division sainsbury's had
a terrible tweet that was uh they
basically said um you know anybody is
welcome to shop in in sainsbury's no
matter what their what their race uh and
if you don't like it go and shop
somewhere else and it's like it's fine
to say you know everybody's welcome to
show up in sainsbury's regardless of the
race i mean i assume that was the case
anyway i wouldn't assume sainsbury's was
racist even though they're owned by the
qatari royals which you know they run a
extremely racist country with a you know
genuinely objectively racist regime um
that actually uses slaves and slavery
you know
it's mad that for all that people bang
on about slavery the only bangalore
about transatlantic slavery that
finished 400 years ago was ended by the
british and nobody bangs on about the
fact that you know there's more slaves
now in the world than the there was
400 years ago the peak of transatlantic
slavery no way and
yeah yeah in china so you've got like um
companies like nike uh and apple using
the weaker muslim uh slaves so they
contract to the chinese government the
chinese government has around about a
million weaker slaves uh held in in work
camps so basically slave labor basically
concentration camps um but slave labor
and they they have to um you know work
for the chinese government um so you
know nikes get get made there and nikes
that are then sold by colin kaepernick
as uh you know this is
we're standing up for minorities it's
the most [ __ ] up
most [ __ ] up world it's great being a
comedian now because there's so much
stuff to talk about in the 90s all i
could talk about was airline food but
now there's all this like you know
genuinely horrific uh you know fascistic
stuff going on
and sainsbury's yes yeah
see so sainsbury's said you know
so you know anybody's welcome to shop in
sainsbury's regardless of their color
and if you don't like it show up
somewhere else it's like well what are
what are the racist supermarkets then if
you're saying
you know sainsbury's is a non-racist
like racist waitress yeah you're saying
waitrose is racist like you know it's
ridiculous obviously none of the
supermarkets are racist because it's
2021.
[ __ ]
i
yeah there's something that feels quite
uncomfortable about
a company that is weaponizing
social justice
ongoing social justice campaigns in
order to
to monetize especially when you think
okay and the underpinnings of this are
total bollocks you know if you were
using it if the byproduct of you
standing for a cause which is genuinely
just was that maybe you gained some
brand equity whatever like that's
happened since the beginning of time but
if you're
creating a fake problem or talking about
a non-existent issue
in order to then try and commercialize
it that just feel
it's the stupidity that annoys me the
most
yeah no absolutely absolutely and the
the cynicism and it's always these
companies that are pretending to be
um
you know super awoke and doing it for
the right reasons when obviously it's an
advertising campaign they've run it
through focus groups and they've had
boards look at it and stuff and uh you
know processed it and being like this is
the thing that's going to sell us more
ice cream like ben and jerry's ben and
jerry's they're constantly uh tweeting
tweeting stuff and tweeting tweeting
abuse at the government for the
treatment of refugees then you go to you
know ben and jerry's like we need to let
all the refugees into the country then
you go down to ben and jerry's they lock
the doors at night it's like so how come
you're we're allowed to enforce that
border like why is the border around ben
and jerry's allowed to be enforced uh
they're all full of nonsense and also um
you know by saying that um
you know they they say that um
ben and jerry's they supported all the
the rioting and the looting in black
lives matter so you should
go and steal ben and jerry's
i saw because i've been out here for a
little while so i missed like all of the
run-up to christmas including the
adverts wasn't there a kick-off about
john lewis as well wasn't wasn't there a
fake scandal around the fact that it was
a black family in the john lewis
campaign which i just thought looked
like a
like a nice it was an average advert but
just a nice family i would be amazed if
there was anything other than a black
family in an advert
uh
you know for another probably about 18
months
and there's certainly no
certainly no white couples all the
couples have to be interracial
um yeah what do you think that's about
why do you think that's happening
because of black lives matter all of a
sudden it all you know the same thing
happened in comedy if you look at tv
comedy it's all um because most
comedians are middle-aged white men bald
white men because
um it's mostly men that want to do it
uh the uk has mostly got white people in
it
and it takes a while to become good at
comedy so by the time you get good
you're like you know 45 or whatever
um so most comedians that are good
enough to watch are you know
middle-aged white men um but if you look
at tv comedy it's all um you know
fat
black women and 22 year olds well what
do you say to people that say well they
haven't had
their time in the limelight this is an
opportunity for previously marginalized
groups to finally get some time on stage
yeah no i think i think it's it's great
i mean if somebody's got a youtube
channel i think it's brilliant that uh
tv is
um you know writing itself into a
relevance
um so you can either go and watch uh you
know a shocking set on live apollo by
you know a non-binary 22 year old
ethnically mysterious
person or you can watch me you know what
i mean
so
it's great long may the bbc continue to
destroy itself is what i see yeah so
is there a
should someone step into a meritocracy
in your id in your view is there a a
point at which there needs to be i don't
know like affirmative action to do with
representation or should it just be a
complete free market
um i think
seriously there needed to be some sort
of uh improvement representation um
and
i still don't think we've got fair
representation maybe um in terms of
ethnicity but not in terms of class
and because people
um
you know if we've got a lack of uh
you know asian asian comedians or black
comedians
um that can be because there aren't
enough black comedians to start off with
so they don't you know if if you're
a black kid
um you're not gonna look at you know or
you might not look at billy connolly and
be like oh yeah i want to be like him
you look at lenny henry or chris rock
because they're black you know what i
mean so you're going to feel that
affinity um so by putting people in
those places you're giving role models
to to the next generation so yeah i
think it is positive i think when it
falls down though is uh you know there's
loads of good um black comedians loads
of good female comedians and they don't
they don't pick when it comes down to
tokenism
when they're they're picking people
according to their demographics like
nico yearwood the guy i do three speech
podcasts with man that guy's just an
absolute killer he's so funny he's so
funny he's got so much charm and
charisma and and wet like
he's great off the cuff his material is
great um he could man that guy could be
could be huge uh but he's not getting
the brakes on tv and it's not just
because he's lazy because he's lazy but
like as
they look at him and they're like nah
boys he's you know he's about 40. um
i don't think he's you know he's not
he's not right for he's not right for us
we want a 22 year old a 22 year old is
going to come out and do like some
absolute dog [ __ ] material about how you
know
um
basically young people aren't funny
because not enough bad stuff has
happened to them
but yeah niko's really funny and he's
not getting the breaks same same with
the female q there's some hilarious
female comedians that don't get a break
because they're
not good looking enough or too good
looking or or whatever it is uh when
when the powers that be are placing
people based on
their demographics is tokenism and it
doesn't it doesn't work but it's never
based on class demographics this is what
rogan said who would have thought that
uh an episode with snoop dogg would have
had some secret wisdom in it but it did
and uh he said
one of the reasons that the powers that
be get people to focus on race is that
it stops us from focusing on class
yeah yeah and i think we know that in
the uk
class is a far bigger differentiator
than race uh
you know obviously like if you talk to
you know i know some um
ethnic people are incredibly positive
calvin robinson for example and um
he you know i don't think he gets uh he
gets a lot of discrimination uh based
based on his or his race but it's you
know
somebody
um
who's got the same ethnicity but his
working class is going to be treated uh
treated a different way and direct you
know if you're dressed a different way
and all the rest of it i've certainly
experienced classism even though like
the thing that pisses me off like in
london i get like you know i got knocked
back for a job at kutz bank uh this back
you know way back in the day and i could
i could sort of tell everybody else in
the interview thing was like super posh
and stuff i could tell i was like man in
scotland i'm posh you know don't be
don't be discreet you think because i'm
scottish i'm not posh but the possious
person in scotland is the poorest person
yeah i'm the poshest person in scotland
you [ __ ] and also your bank's
owned by the royal bank of scotland so
like you know give me my [ __ ] give me
my nation's desire yeah exactly yeah
[ __ ] what have you got coming up next
what's next on the plate for you
so yeah hopefully i'm gonna get over
omicron soon have you had to rearrange a
ton of dates
uh yeah i just i cancelled the but i was
supposed to headline for the free speech
union gig last night um
and i was supposed to be up in blackpool
and
liverpool and burskoff or whatever it's
called um this weekend but i've had to
cancel those
um so yeah i'm just i'm i'm just taking
the the opportunity to write stuff from
my youtube channel so i'll be doing a
new video i'm gonna do a video next
about walk sports people so you've got
the sports personality of the year
competition coming up in the 19th so i'm
gonna do and all these people are like
man marcus rashford you know he's all
the government needs to you know
government needs to um provide free
school meals to all the children and
stuff then he's dodging his taxes he's
paying himself with the loan so you know
you don't need to pay tax on a loan you
can just not pay the loan back so you
know if he paid his taxes the government
if all these people all these walk
people more people are always the
government needs to do this it's like
man you can give the government more
money if you want i don't want to give
the government any more money but you
can soon as you think it's so important
now the government can afford to give it
you know all the kids can get a free
school meal and a faberge egg or
whatever else they want like you know
what i mean it's ridiculous gary lineker
gary lineker's always like swanning
around twitter being all like you know
criticizing lawrence fox or whoever for
for being terrible people and it's like
gary lineker makes his money
from the bbc which is basically
taxpayers money and then he like he
decides he doesn't have enough money
from all the hundreds of thousands of
pounds he gets each year from the bbc so
he sells crisps he markets crisps to
obese children who are at risk of
diabetes
so he's basically he's basically
deliberately killing children for money
it's like you can't he's basically like
gaddafi's son
gary lineker is an absolute you know
what i mean for these people to then try
and take the moral high ground it's like
how about you stop killing children gary
it's like you'd be selling cigarettes at
a playground out of the back of a van if
you're his choice but instead you know
he's selling walker's christmas instead
woke personality of the year then so
that's done where can people go if they
want to check out their youtube channel
yes i've got youtube channel just leo
kearse um
that's how you find it or my instagram's
scottish comedian all one no way you've
got scottish comedian on instagram yeah
yeah i can't believe it's available
either [ __ ] you daniel
[ __ ] you yeah
man it's been really good to speak today
i hope that you get over your own macron
and you have a good christmas and i will
catch you in the new year what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe peace